oui le point ne sont pas les américains
à partir du moment où vous avez une
domination économique et militaire sur
le monde vous essayez d'imposer votre
loi en gros les anglais les français ont
dû faire à peu près là où j'en veux à
fait la même chose on a parlé on a fait
la même chose les anglais ont fait la
même chose les romains ont fait la même
chose donc rien de nouveau
le problème c'est notre réaction nous
entre clubs européens
là ça va très très lent on a parlé de
l'iran mais on peut parler aussi du
gazoduc entre la russie et l'allemagne
le nord stream 2 qui est censé
repositionner l'allemagne et le reste de
l'europe en gaz russe
les preuves possibles a dit qu'il allait
sanctionner les entreprises européennes
qui construisaient ce gazoduc donc où on
met des entreprises en fait si vous
voulez dans un conflit de lois c'est
qu'à partir du moment où vous faites ou
réaliser un projet où vous ne signez un
contrat il ya tout un tas de lois qui
s'appliquent à votre contrat vous avez
votre propre loi vous avez le loi de la
loi du pays vous avez la loi américaine
vous avez la loi anglaise on n'a pas
parlé mais les anglais font exactement
la même chose et un moment vous allez
devoir faire un choix en tant que patron
d'entreprise soient respectés telle loi
soit respectée tel autre loi et vous
allez forcément un moment de voir chez
quelqu'un vous fâchez vous fâcher à
quelqu'un le problème c'est que voit pas
quand on est une grande entreprise d'une
grande banque prenait l'exemple de la
bnp tout à l'heure mais vous pouvez pas
vous fâcher avec les états unis
appartenant ou la menace et de dire vous
ne faites plus de transactions en
dollars vous tuer la banque
donc vous n'avez pas d'autre choix que
en fait de respecter ce que la loi du
plus fort c'est la même chose avec total
lorsque total se retire de l'iran parce
que les états unis ont dénoncé l'accord
avec avec l'iran bien évidemment totale
est obligée de se retirer de lire parce
qu'il ya d'autres intérêts donc le
problème ne peut pas être réglé connu
une entreprise il faut qu'ils aient une
une réaction politique
[Musique]